hello
and welcome to what's new ananthus
in this session we will go over exciting
new additions to anthos which will make
it even more easier for you to manage
and secure your multi-cloud and hybrid
applications
we have been working hard to add more
features expand reach and simplify the
experiences to make amthos the best
application modernization platform
i'm analog jain and i lead product
management for anthems at google
joining us in this session is my
colleague lisa chen
hi everyone my name is elisa shen and i
am a google cloud product manager
before we dive deep here is a quick
introduction for those who are new to
inputs
let's go back a few years
we created kubernetes to maximize
productivity of our own developers at
google and then we open sourced it to
help others achieve the same
to make humanity's production ready we
created google kubernetes engine or gke
as we call it the best way to consume
kubernetes as a reliable secure and
fully managed service
in 2019 we introduce anthus a managed
platform designed to simplify the
management of kubernetes cluster or any
public or private cloud by extending a
gke-like experience along with our best
open source frameworks
and thus extends google engineering
practices to your environment so that
you can modernize your apps faster and
establish operational consistency across
them from a single pane of glass
it helps you minimize operational
overhead as you scale your
infrastructure and helps you reduce the
total cost of ownership
containerization offers a common
application packaging format across
different infrastructure types and
kubernetes offers consistent apis and
control mechanisms
and those can be used for application
deployments on your existing virtual
machines
or bare metal servers or even another
public cloud like aws and azure besides
google cloud
anthony is made up of a few core
components
infrastructure management
provides a reliable and efficient way to
deploy and run containers and manage
them across any environment
next is application service management
it provides managed service mesh to
connect manage and secure containers
we extend the capabilities of amthos to
run serverless applications as well
it also has a wide selection of
production ready development stacks and
services
operation management is an integrated
logging and monitoring service for your
containers services and applications
policy management and security
management are central to manage
configuration and security policies
across your fleet and it helps you
reduce your operational cost
at the same time enforce security
posture that's right for your
applications
with that
we are now ready to jump right in and
talk about the new and exciting
additions to alphas
and thus multi-cloud allows container
orchestration standardization
across clouds via a new managed service
with this new service we've also added
support for infos and azure
both of these are in preview with ga
coming right around the corner
so now
you can deploy google kubernetes
clusters to gcp aws and azure directly
from google cloud
you can control all cluster lifecycle
operations centrally you can review
system and application logs and monitor
clusters across all clouds through
single pane of glass
cluster lifecycle operations can be
controlled by a gcloud api or terraform
allowing for a completely automated
workflow
as a result you get consistent unified
and secure cluster and container
management on a cloud of your choice
in addition to centralized logging and
monitoring you benefit from our connect
gateway which allows for google cloud to
be the central access point for each
cluster we will talk more about it in a
minute
after you've deployed kubernetes fabric
in your environment the next step is to
deploy cluster level configuration
policy and finally application specs
using anta's configuration management
service you can sync gke and non-gke
cluster to a git repo that defines the
guardrail for your organization
the repo can include config maps network
policies
necessary agents and so on
policy configurations can also be
located in the ripple to enforce best
practices or custom rules set by your
organization for example you can set
policies to actively block non-compliant
api requests or simply to audit the
configuration of your clusters and
report violations
such as application without proper
labels
configuration specs can be applied to
all clusters or just a subset using
cluster selected object
any changes to the config in the repo
will be absorbed automatically by the
cluster
and besides gke anthony supports cnc of
confirmed kubernetes clusters like aks
or eks giving you the option to keep
your application running on your
favorite kubernetes and still take
advantage of antho services
next is anthon bare metal
it lets you deploy kubernetes clusters
directly on your own servers giving you
the best performance and flexibility
options
you have direct control over application
scale security network latency
by running containerized application on
gke
and benefit from anthon's components
running locally
we have made a number of announcements
recently to answers on pl metal such as
providing container d as a default
runtime
adding registry mirroring that helps you
insulate from any service outages over
the network and helps improve the
security
we have also reduced
minimum system requirement for running
anthrax and bare metal by over 50
percent for edge use cases
now you will only need one node with two
b cpus and only four gigabytes of memory
to run 9000 bare metal
that means
more compute and more memory available
for your applications
it reduces the overall tco when you have
many edge locations with a small
footprint
anthon vmware brings google kubernetes
engine to on-premise data centers
with broad support for vsphere platforms
including the latest stable release 7-0
we have rolled out a number of features
on anthony's vmware this year
for example
with the cluster backup and restore
feature you can now set up admin cluster
backups to perform automatically before
and after cluster creation
or upgrade for user admin clusters you
can also perform an on-demand backup
whenever you deem it necessary
another feature is user cluster auto
scaling which resizes the number of
nodes in a given node pool based on
demand of your workloads you don't need
to manually add or remove nodes or even
over provision your node post to
guarantee availability and thereby
adding to the cost
instead you can specify your minimum and
maximum size for the load pull and the
rest is taken care automatically
last year we announced support for
windows servers containers on gcp
which lets you take advantage for
containers without putting your
applications to net code or rewriting
them
we have now enabled support for windows
server containers and answer vmware in
your on-prem environment
by running windows and linux workloads
side by side you get operational
consistency and efficiency
there is no need to have multiple teams
specializing in different tooling or
platforms to manage different workloads
mixed workloads
can be configured on a single cluster as
well
giving you even more flexibility
the ability to manage policies from a
central control plane further simplifies
the management experience
while bin packing multiple windows
application drives better resource
utilizations leading to infrastructure
and license cost savings
we have recently made anthony's connect
gateway generally available for our
customers
it provides a single google hosted front
door allowing for customers to use their
existing tooling to effortlessly access
and thus connected clusters running
anywhere
it solves key pain points we have heard
from many customers deploying on-prem at
the edge or even on other clouds
accessing kubernetes cluster can be a
challenge and they often resort to using
jump holes or vpns to these clusters
connect gateway simplifies the
connectivity challenge by using the same
infrastructure that powers existing
connected and those uis
this service authenticates
and authorizes gcp users and forwards
their requests to the connect agents
running in the cluster
and ultimately the clusters capabilities
api server as a result
you get consistent and secure way to use
your existing kubernetes tooling to
perform common operations against any
fleet registered communities cluster
a key building block for anthem's
infrastructure management is our
software defined networking
sdn capabilities in anthes extend the
full networking stack from layer 2 to
layer 7
and it's built on best-in-class
kubernetes open source infrastructure
we have extended the capabilities with
innovations such as node network
firewalls to protect workload at
infrastructure level
load balancing for kubernetes workload
is bundled in by taking in solutions
like metal lb and extending it for layer
4 layer 7 use cases as well as
integrating bjp support into it
we also enable connectivity of workloads
across hybrid environments with easy to
deploy vpn solution and provide
consistent observability and
supportability tools
there are two important features that we
have introduced in android's networking
stack this year
and those data plan v2 is optimized for
kubernetes networking it is an
opinionated data plane that leverages
celia
an open source project that makes the
linux kernels kubernetes aware using evp
app
it delivers a unified user experience
for configurations deployments and
monitoring of networking features across
google cloud hybrid and even other cloud
environments
it makes ports a first-class citizen of
networking ecosystem with better
performance and visibility
another key feature is anthon's
networking gateway
which provides a number of advanced
networking features for hybrid and
multi-cloud environments for example
egressnet enables you to have a
deterministic ip
for ignis traffic with namespace and
label granularity with multi-cluster
connectivity you get direct power
reachability between environments
i hope you're as excited about these
editions as we are and wait we have a
lot more to talk about
i'll invite lisa to share more exciting
capabilities that we've added to others
thank you a lot now let's take a look at
ansel's configuration management it
enables you to automatically deploy a
shared environment configurations and
enforce approved security policies
across kubernetes clusters on premises
on gke and in other public cloud
platforms
as part of enso's configuration
management we have recently announced a
new feature available called config
controller a hosted service to provision
and orchestrate google cloud resources
the service offers an
api endpoint that can provision and
orchestrate more than 120 google cloud
resources the same way it manages
kubernetes resources with continuous
monitoring and self-healing
as a host data service you don't have to
install or manage the components of the
config controller
or be an expert in kubernetes resource
management because google cloud will
manage them for you
config controller provisions
infrastructure applications and cloud
services configs them to your desired
intent and monitor them for the
configuration drift
config changes are as easy as a git push
and can be easily integrated with your
development workflows
another exciting new feature we
introduced this year is the acm
multi-repo support enabling multi-revo
mode lets you sync configurations from
multiple repositories to the same set of
clusters
an example is shown in the diagram here
the platform admin manages the
centralized infrastructure for the
organization and enforces policies on
the cluster and on all namespaces in the
org
the application developers who are
responsible for managing live
deployments applied configurations to
applications in the namespaces they work
on
the multi-repo feature decouples the
config deployment life cycle for
different teams
it provides you with more autonomy and
flexibility and you get to choose where
you want to place the ripple and how to
structure it
micro service architectures present
numerous benefits but also introduce
challenges like added complexity and the
fragmentation for different workloads
and source service mesh which is a
google fully managed service simplifies
service delivery across the board from
traffic management and mesh telemetry to
securing communications between
different services
we have many exciting new features
rolled out in asm this year and all of
these are ensourced value add over the
istual open source project
with the managed asm control plan on gcp
google is responsible for the
availability scalability and security of
the control plan
we also have managed certificate agent
on gcp and manage the proxy updates
based on the release channels
both sre dashboard with service level
objectives and the security insights
dashboard are available to give you
in-depth visibility into the application
services
with the application security inside
dashboard you will have a 360 degree
view of workload security you get a
summary of the security configuration
with the workload drill down view to
troubleshoot security issues
in addition you can now add a google
compute engine vms in managed instance
groups to a service mesh you'll get same
observability telemetry and security
capabilities as you would get from
running services on source gke clusters
in the mesh
enso's identity service is
authentication proxy for answers that
enables customers to authenticate their
users to enso's environment using their
existing identity solutions
ais simplifies identity management
across hybrid and multi-cloud
deployments by providing a common
authentication abstraction layer for all
the n-source environments
as a result you can leverage your
existing identity investment with enzos
using standard identity protocols such
as ldap or oidc or you can consistently
apply your policies across the
environments
it simplifies your cross-environment
workload migration
enso's workload identity feature enables
kubernetes workload hosted on any
cluster to authenticate to google cloud
or other services in a consistent way we
have extended gke workload identity
concept to enso's platforms on-prem and
in multi-counts
the workload identity federation feature
eliminates the need for long-lived
credentials and replaces them with
short-lived auto-rotated credentials
it enables consistent authentication
across all the clusters
the feature not only helps application
developers to connect applications to
essential services easier but also helps
the platform admin to maintain the
governance across the clusters
on the application management side i'm
very excited that we will have enso's
hybrid ci cd available for public
preview in november this year
built on top of the existing google
cloud belt and google cloud deploy
solution enso's hybrid ci cd will allow
customers to build and deploy
containerized applications seamlessly to
hybrid and multi-cloud environments
using a single control plan
hybrid cluster hybrid cloud on cluster
ci cd is ideal for customers that are
prohibited from connecting their source
control or artifact repos to gcp due to
organizational network or security
requirements
more specifically this will allow
customers to run ci cd workloads with
their private network with simplified
network configurations that don't rely
upon network appearing in addition the
on-cluster ci cd also reduces the
latency for accessing local resources
another popular tool included in enzo's
product is the end migrate for exos and
gke
migrate for insults and gke
intelligently extracts migrates and
modernizes applications to run natively
on containers in gke and enzos clusters
it makes it easy and fast to modernize
traditional applications away from
virtual machines and into native
containers
you can migrate vms running on vmware
aws or azure into containers managed by
enso's in real time and capitalize on
increased resource utilization unified
logging and monitoring and modern
application life cycle management tools
a recent feature that we've introduced
is called a migrate feed assessment tool
which helps customers discover their
inventory and assess fit for
containerization
it replaces the existing lightweight
discovery tool and it runs completely
disconnected from the internet
in addition migrate for insoles and gke
now supports enhanced container runtime
such as enso's cloud one how run is a
managed compute platform that enables
you to run status containers that are
invokable by web requests or pops up
events
the enhancements let you deploy your
migrated container workloads on the
cloud run
you can learn more about insoles via
google cloud product website or explore
our powerful multi-cluster kubernetes
management features with the nso's
sample deployment tutorial when you are
ready be sure to schedule application
assessment workshop with your google
team to begin planning your application
modernization journey thank you for
watching the show and i hope you have a
great day
thanks lisa and thank you everyone for
being with us on what's new with others
we hope you enjoy the rest of the google
next 2021
you